[Music]
i got you bro i'm on the way
but you don't understand
it's the hardest threat of all oh my god
it's the vegan teacher
no
not the vegan teacher who's that
i don't know you clearly know who it is
i just saw it on the reddit man i just
saw like the vegan teacher i was like oh
great another vegan who thinks she's
better than everyone you know teaching
people all right here we go
she looks really humble and nice maybe
she uh she's really nice who knows yeah
maybe you're right maybe you're right
maybe
maybe i'm wrong i passed my first
assignment apparently so probably
congratulations
is that the first time ever i didn't
know what the assignment was but i
passed cool
that's how big brain you are that's how
on top of things you are good job oh
gosh another vegan huh i feel like we've
been here before kim yeah when's the
last time this happened to you it was
like six years ago seven years ago
they always come crawling back they're
never satisfied what does she have to
say let's check it out hello students
and especially to you pewdiepie
pewdiepie is a new student here in class
and look i never asked to join this
class
she's calling you out directly
[Laughter]
congratulations he is giving us a
presentation and already it's starting
off great he's got fries which are vegan
what the [ __ ]
i never showed this image what is this
what's i put this in here save you're
there
save what have you done
so congratulations you did it oh my god
felix you're the guy that in group
group studies everyone else did the work
and you just take credit for it you're
that guy right now oh my god no how did
you know i'm that guy come on come on
bro come up right come on come over here
dude in college everyone in the group
thought i did so little that they they
just said like you got to do the group
presentation but you got to do it alone
we're not going to do it with you
[ __ ] dick move dude i tried at least
okay but did you
everyone else was so hard working i
didn't know where to slink in there you
know
they were just doing such a good job
interesting such a great job i didn't
know where i was going to do the job
as well well how did the presentation go
did you give it i
nailed it no it was probably terrible i
don't even know it was weird that was
weird times man [ __ ] nerds at college
vegan burger packed with veggies there
and he also has some vegan nuggets this
is great so i'm going to be how does she
know how does she know she can just look
at things and tell her hey she's got
vegan senses okay she knows she's okay
she can feel
she can feel the vegetables that burger
looks nasty what the [ __ ] is all like
i thought that was like i thought they
had a bunch of meat on there in the
middle honestly when i saw it i thought
that was a straight up like uh asperger
with some money on it come on
okay okay okay can once you become a
student you will also be able to tell
the difference
you understand
okay i got you but why why would i why
would i care
let's see what she has to say a little
card here with um i'm gonna write uh
good over here bad and his name and
we're going to be giving him an
evaluation a report card and i hope that
he's going to get a good mark i have a
feeling that he is
[Music]
taking a lifetime more just a minute
it's too early for this i can't do this
camp
oh dancing over here a good song oh
sorry all right
[Music]
everywhere around the world animals are
lining up to thank you for your
compassion and for allowing your heart
to open it keeps going jesus christ
let's begin declaration day that an
actual day should google that
uh shouldn't vegan baby every day can
huh huh hey are you vegan you just being
one day of the year huh
i'm not vegan and actually you're not
vegan neither so how'd you pass
that's what i want to know okay
i haven't had to hear your
it's going to be very big stories so
much
but uh women have a natural
affinity towards this you know they want
to yeah
people on the internet know better than
to start trying to call you out because
the backlash is just like you
automatically won
that's nothing
i think it's the first option again
are you here just to tear me down ken hi
no no no i'm just being cynical sorry
let's stop it good job you pass i love
you man you know the last time i heard
about you was so long ago my sons when
they were teenagers they watched you one
day they were watching you and i was
like turn off that crap don't watch this
guy because you were just talking about
all kinds of nonsense but i see that you
seem to be evolving and growing up thank
you everybody does and now you're
talking about you're showing vegan food
here yeah i am showing vegan food there
i did that outside
let's go you've really grown you've
really grown you know i've grown a lot
this is like one of those like she's
like one of those people that's stopping
the road be like oh man can i get a
picture i like never watch you and i
hated your old videos but hey you know
absolutely
let me get some that clown bruh
[Laughter]
i used to watch your videos is ten times
better than my uh little brother loves
you or my sibling i'm like all right
well where are they then
uh it's it's so it's so kind you've
really grown up you know you've really
impressed her good job you're not the
same piece of trash you used to be you
have a vegan burger on your screen i
used to talk about nonsense now i show
vegan burgers on my screen heck yeah no
more nonsense from you let's kill this
[ __ ] and add the most vegan burgers on
the screen at what you've ever seen
[Music]
your presentation is apparently about
fish and you're going to be talking
about how badly they are treated i don't
know i'm super excited so i'm gonna i
think you do know i think you watched
this video more already
i'm gonna press over here
and let's see
to find out how more food is made
starting off with the number one
delicious meal aquarium fish aquarium
she has nothing to say about that she
had nothing to say about that at all
[Laughter]
she was like yeah these meat eaters
they're crazy they eat anything anyway
not surprising right let me write your
i'm just going to ignore
have that around for hundreds of years
even now is she writing out marks as she
yeah she is
seems like magic the most common
aquarium now he dies and it says water
necklace
exactly pewdiepie there's nothing
magical
about taking fish and putting them in a
tight container
you just got your first check mark this
is
crazy
yeah this is really cringe
it's it's not
okay
it's not it's not reverse at all
yeah
exactly yeah
it's not right to take any kind of fish
out of their natural habitat and shove
them into glass containers or swimming
pools we shouldn't be taking whales out
of the oceans or dolphins and putting
them into places like sea world that is
wrong
animals are here with us on the planet
they're not here for us to stare at and
to treat like objects
no i got nothing to say i don't know
be careful you know
why
you've been making
she's coming for you next you're the one
no no she doesn't care about me
and i'm definitely not vegan and i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm gonna eat all the cow
meat i want to so uh
is the most dangerous animal in uk yeah
that's why i gotta eat them okay i gotta
eat all of them i'm doing this for you
people die of cows more than any other
animal is that true i heard that
i actually don't eat that much red meat
at all but i don't shy away from if it
shows you're sounding like my parents
now can't stop it yeah yeah i mean
mary's their whole family is very
conscious about this kind of stuff so
it's like
yeah it's just rubbing off on me i'm
slowly changing maybe one day i'll pass
but not today cows are the most
dangerous animals in britain we need to
eradicate them
look at it look how evil it looks it's
freaking
the devil oh
did you see the you haven't been on
twitter in a long time let me let me
tell me
i gotta show you but how do people die
from them they get mowed over because
they're out there trying to tip them you
know little cow tipping
the cow kicks them dead 74 people here
people here jesus wow
how uh have you ever have you ever been
cow tipping before i would never you
would never i would never
never ever
i
[Music]
in the fields right and you go out there
and you run you shove them over and they
go
they tip over and it's hilarious yeah
but don't they have to get like a crane
to lift them back up
no
[Music]
i mean have you ever seen a cow lay down
the ground no have you ever seen a cow
before yes i live in the uk actually
cows all the time
they're watching from your window right
now
i put something in the in the discord
for you
[Music]
oh hell yeah
yeah this makes me thirsty for some milk
man oh
man yeah yeah
good old pitas on it ah they're so dumb
they use it as a for people to call them
out and then they'd be like oh yeah well
here's some knowledge on it i'm like yo
big brain you got us
amazing thanks well let's see my grade
here ken this is important i noticed
that you had all kinds of vegan foods
here i mean first of all i don't know
what the heck this other thing is i
don't yeah yeah that's not excellent if
that's today
that's broccoli that was broccoli don't
worry
[Laughter]
broccoli pie did animals that's not food
but you have here let's let's put some
chicken she loves his image the fact
that
that's it that's like the only part of
the video that she can really show it
looks like that's vegan spices are vegan
you also have a bun there and bread is
vegan for the most part it doesn't have
eggs in it you gotta check though but
most bread is okay
and you have something in the bun which
is either a vegan burger like a beyond
burger or it could be beans in there
made from beans or could be made from
lentils so i'm giving you check marks
for that you also have other veggies in
there you have it looks like some uh
does she understand that
i haven't made this burger this is a i
don't know
of a burger that my editor put in and i
don't know why we don't know anything
about this burger is that like a chicken
nugget down there at the bottom left
this whole thing
yeah it's like
the fries could be cooked in uh oil same
as meat i mean the burger could not be
boy you're right i'm learning a lot
today
just vegan and it looks like you have a
piece of vegan cheese in there i don't
know if that's what it is but something
yeah it's vegan cheese yeah yeah make
sure you never get the dead animal
nuggets always get the vegan version and
of course they are wrapped in bread
crumbs and bread crumbs are vegan bro i
gotta say vegan nuggets taste exactly
the same as normal nuggets yeah yes they
are identical i believe you yeah that
one i feel like should be the standard
because it's like whatever it's [ __ ]
nuggets what is it
yeah have you ever seen the the video
where the dude shows all the the
kindergarten kids how they make chicken
nuggets yeah
and at the end he's like who wants a
nugget they're like me
they just don't care he's trying to
prove how gross it is and they're just
like yes
yes give him those nuggets
i feel bad because before we start this
video i'm my role is to be like the
cynical one and
you know say all the stuff but now i
just feel like i'm attacking vegans
everywhere which i guess they deserve it
because
they're attacking everybody that's right
his face of disappointment is so good
[Laughter]
i know jamie oliver is a super nice dude
but i hate seeing his face he's
everywhere in the uk dude just because i
said i swear to [ __ ] god you enter a
bookstore and his face is always there
and i'm like how many goddamn books can
this guy make how not enough apparently
he's more
he's still making books how many books
can you make i go to a gas station jamie
oliver i go to cinema jamie oliver he's
following me like a shadow jamie oliver
get out of my face please who's jim is
this guy jamie oliver yes the naked [ __ ]
he's got a world of warcraft cooking
book what he's got 15 minute feeds he's
got the ultimate that's gordon ramsay
yeah success that's too small to be this
dude
bro who's buying all this but look at it
many bucks nobody ever make sorry jamie
you seem lovely by the way
the red-headed ginger singer that
was his name
oh eddie and sharon the most beautiful
man alive oh yeah it looks like him in
some of these pictures right maybe maybe
one of the twins from harry potter i
can't tell they're very similar
he's got that uh oh british jeans yeah
they're very very strong what do you
mean what do you mean with that ken
character elaborate
look at this oh some of them are the
same anyway because these come from
terrible cycles of violence
oh and there's another burger there well
you get another oh my god stop it with
this photo how much can you analyze a
photo jesus christ we're bad ken we go
on tangents for hours
but this is the comfort this is next
level man
i don't even know if you could talk five
minutes about just a picture that's
something about a burger that we don't
know is actually vegan or not yeah i
didn't even know he put this in and i
watched the video like twice i'm so
proud of you pewdiepie you seem to
really be growing up this is amazing
thank you growing up you're growing
that's not coming
to anyone yeah not at all
here and and go again to where we were
here
right domesticated in china more than
one thousand oh my god we're still in
the satire bed not for it shouldn't be
treated badly and you have to feel it in
your heart you can see that he is
starting to feel so i'm giving you
another chance for that
i got it feeling scared
i'm like you
you got feet
and i got feelings
oh my god that is me what are you and me
i got more feelings for you
oh wow
i got way more feelings
oh if only she knew yeah feelings of
hate and disgust and sarcasm is that
even a feeling i don't know yes it is
and she noticed thank you
[Laughter]
look she does she's just making up stuff
at this point dude
i wonder if the reason she's so nice is
that she mentioned her sons maybe
they're like fans or something so she
want to be nice but for them yeah
all right all right she's being nice
because she's got 70 000 subscribers
right now and she's got to put you and
mr beast and everyone else in her
thumbnails and you know not though you
can put me under the bus so there's not
a whole bunch of backlash she's trying
to build positivity you know she's gotta
i think literally watching 50 seconds
into your video just to find anything
good to talk about for six minutes
i think she's being nice because she
recognized niceness ken
listen to you oh my god
is this the path you're taking right now
all right this page doesn't it ken huh
people finally recognize these nice
things you're like oh person i am kid
thank you
let's hear more what vegan teacher has
to say okay
they're sick that's sick they're sick or
does it mean they're sick questioning
very good you understand
[Music]
a good question bro
i question ken but you wouldn't question
that
good job
i don't know what the [ __ ] she said by
questioning nicely mark look at her
handling them
as if she's handling cutlery taking
forks and knives out i think she handled
them actually pretty decently if you
notice how they normally handle like
separation and stuff like that oh is it
pretty bad yeah watch this video but
only strong goldfish are sold to the
public like that wasn't that bad right
if you had to separate fish she could
have just yeah you know
it's just gonna like you know kobe can
hit it you know
too soon um what yeah it didn't seem
that bad really
what is she doing thank you pewdiepie
for acknowledging that this is not
normal behavior we shouldn't be handling
objects you fish like that
are you saying what because she's
looking at the butt of the fish
yeah
that's what i thought
like what is she doing what is she
checking out down there
oh man look at the dislike ratio on this
thing i just noticed that yeah
yeah people don't like her she likes you
though so that that goes a long way
i mean i can how can anyone not like me
ken
all right that would be like somebody i
see you're busy drinking we'll we'll get
back to that we shouldn't breathe these
fish do not belong out of the water
giving you another check mark good job
raised by workers i think i'm killing to
determine you're doing really good oh
what
stop stop exactly did you hear him he
said stop just like any man should thank
you beauty
i like your reactions you're totally
completely different
she's reacting of like shock concern and
you're reacting because something's
coming that fish's butt no no it was
compassion again something you break
really cannot understand
another check mark for you good job good
thank you thank you the animals
suffering or sees them suffering should
immediately yell stop stop it hurting
stop
that's what i did ken yeah that's what
you that's exactly what you did right
yep right here so proud of you
thank you you're getting another check
mark for that that's right
lay that goddamn goldfish along leave
the goldfish a little absolutely
absolutely cute uh cutie pie oh oh my
god oh oh oh a little freudian sleepy
revealing your true
[Music]
can't help it natural charm can
what is wrong with people thank you
pewdiepie for saying no to this and for
saying it loudly and clearly okay all
right all right all right please
can we move on we made it past the stock
image photo
can we
what do they call this it's like
whenever you have animals and you like
project it's projection you project your
personality onto them like she's doing a
lot of projecting on you right now you
haven't actually said any of the stuff
that she's saying you have this video
yet
no in the context of the video you
haven't actually said what you're saying
you're saying
i think she understands
she oh she's in there she understands
her thinking's a pewdiepie she knows
yeah
wonderful i'm so proud of you this is so
great pewdiepie i am so proud of you
right now
oh my god you've realized the first time
i ever heard anyone say that
sad and hilarious at the same time
but you're doing great now i should if
you become vegan i'm going to tell all
the children to watch you i really hope
that you'll be that will that would
really boost my subscribers maybe a
hundred you have maybe a hundred billion
million did you see how she like looked
off screen a couple times she said that
like i don't believe her she's kind of
like glanced over like uh yeah i'll tell
definitely tell all the kids to watch
you all the kids i don't want the kids
[ __ ] now i gotta eat me i don't want the
kids watching me how could you the
betrayal she's gonna be so disappointed
in you do you know what a difference
you'll make i don't have that many
followers so it's really hard for me to
get my message out and so
then that your that basically means
nothing then that you're gonna tell all
the children
thanks
thanks people are being cruel just have
a look at my comment section pewdiepie
once i get going let's have a look at
the comment section pewdiepie let's take
a look
what does it say down there let's see i
don't know i don't know
ah the memes from the reddit there we go
humanity's evolving just backwards
she's taking everything he's saying out
of context and giving them different
meaning pewdiepie intended plus he's
even vegan
average discarded
there's this card in light mode that
actually exists i don't know does it oh
my god she's putting words in pewds
ma'am um put burgers and stuff which
looks like veggies in thumbnail wow
happy vegan day
what is in your recommended over there
holy crap
a bunch of your videos the the oh yeah
my videos cool i'll watch the most
banned hint i ever made wow well that's
vegan so that's cool hell yeah you wanna
click on that
i know which one that is
which one is it
well you you fly it outside and on a
windy day
um
what i don't know if i just say it
because we have a large platform maybe i
shouldn't inform people what it's called
all right
i don't know i don't know i'm going
vegan here i'm trying to save the planet
you're learning right now ken
you're actually growing up right now as
we're watching this
i'm growing out actually had a big
dinner
put some turkey in it
no
[Music]
vegan turkey of course
of course a vegan turkey yes yes of
course i've actually had that i was
grossed this out and the animals are
suffering so much they're going through
a holocaust right now you know what they
did to the jews in world war two
all right hope all right vegan teacher i
will have to just
skip ahead on that little monologue
just go ahead
we don't need that
that's so offensive
they put them in a blender they cut them
up into a million pieces they murdered
them on their first day of being born
because they'll never be able to lay
eggs i actually kind of i don't know
what she's talking about but you know
they they eat the cows right because
it's such t it's nice tender meat that i
was kind of thought that was messed up
yeah it is like what they call it uh
veal veal that's right and they put it
they put it in like uh
cheese i think there's in cheddar well
i've seen the videos about like what
goes on in the the meat processing
plants and all that so i mean yeah yeah
better off that they get a they get done
in early
honestly that's a good point well this
is weird i'm like [ __ ] cheese you
have to put they oh they put the the
stomach of the the cow or something like
that i don't know it doesn't matter and
in the dairy industry it's also a cycle
of violence i'm just trying to get good
points for part two of this camp yeah
good night
the reaction to the reaction i got you
she's gonna
i'm gonna be hated
don't worry about anything you said i'm
just gonna be like who is this guy if
you grow up one of these things can
things will get better they're taking
away their babies and the babies are
crying because they want to be with
their mothers and then they take the
babies and they slit their throats and
they use their skin to make leather
handbags and shoes and they use their
bodies and they turn them into veal and
they put them in styrofoam trays it's
awful
it's awful
and i really need your help pewdiepie so
i'm so happy that you're becoming vegan
she crying at least i hope you are
pulling them in no i'm i'm not vegan and
i don't care to become vegan because i
just think it's a title that people care
about i'll eat whatever i want well no
you gotta become vegan so that way you
can make videos judging other people's
veganism that's getting to the point to
where you have enough of a following to
where they will have to do whatever you
say you just bully your way around you
know
heck yeah just like previous vegans have
made videos about you the same thing the
best way to really convince people is to
shame them vegans have adopted this
better than anyone that's true
although she's uh she's trying so hard
not to do it though
so i don't know what yeah she's actually
doing this pretty well honestly like
even though she's putting a lot of words
in your mouth she's not being very uh
toxic it's not as bad as i've seen right
i expected her to be toxic like typical
toxic vegan but it's especially looking
at the liking dislike it's just kind of
cringe
[Applause]
of all the strong goldfish are forced to
mate with each other no
oh my god that is right i'm not supposed
to laugh i know it's serious
i like the face that she just falls down
today wait hold up i've learned this
fish don't actually you know
they don't
do that they don't do that yeah they
fertilize the eggs outside i don't know
how it works they just rub their parts
together they have babies yeah
so it's not even actually that that is
not what is happening here ken i mean i
guess they didn't have con they didn't
have consent of course
uh god what a freaking oh what a rabbit
hole to go down to try to be
politically correct and like it's a fish
though
can i say that what do you mean what is
the point i don't get it they're making
the fish do the no-no no but what i'm
telling you that's not what's happening
here that's not what's happening
okay
what's happening i don't know they're
just like checking them out i don't know
and just rubbing them together i spent
like an hour trying to find two fish
slamming it out they don't do that
okay
they don't i thought they did with like
i guess it depends on what kind of fish
it is like i think like salmon like they
just like throw it out in the water or
something yes exactly yes that's what
i'm trying to tell you oh
well that's even worse because then
there's just these random fish swimming
around that didn't ask for that and all
of a sudden they're having all these
fish babies come on you're just trying
to
i'm sorry
all of you men out there that is what
you should be looking for that's what a
real man looks like
that's what a real man looks like this
is what a real man in the thumbnail
looks like right here
getting another check mark thank you so
much
no another note oh my god stop with the
notes
count them bro count them
let's go
now
i am stopping this just what every human
who sees violence she's stopping it now
she's only a minute and 30 seconds in
the video oh my goodness pewdiepie
this could be the beginning of something
so wonderful
oh my gosh i wonder when your vegan
declaration day will be oh so that's
what declaration day means oh you
declare you're vegan
who does she keep looking at off-screen
does someone have a gun to her head like
there's a pewdiepie fan out there like
pointing a gun and be like don't you say
anything bad because he's like
trust me
see anything we got the nine-year-old
cindy infiltrated and stronger goldfish
the fertilized eggs are placed into
separate containers oh my gosh this is
awful okay pewdiepie listen up i want
you to go to she had nothing to say
about selective breeding
nothing nothing to say about that
all right all right
not important to some people all right
let's see my grade what's my crane i
want to know my gray can this is all my
recycled cardboard by the way here we go
see when you have when you have boxes of
cereal or crackers or whatever you can
cut it up and you can reuse that
better for the environment what did you
get what the [ __ ] is my grain you passed
because you actually did a really good
job today thank you so much pewdiepie yo
[Music]
i don't have to be a vegan this is great
wow
is that how many times you said no in
that one spot with all those check marks
oh man this wasn't as bad as i thought
it was going to be i know i would
i feel kind of bad for being as
competitive as i was at first because
you did it for the memes and i
appreciate it that was funny yeah but
she still only watched a minute and 30
seconds of your video and made like a 50
minute video about it that's that's not
we could we should learn something from
her
honestly
that's next level youtube well how do
you feel now that you've passed and
you're not vegan well clearly i never
had to become a vegan so that's great
that's that's a win
you see because can i am what's better
than vegan
pescatarian gang [ __ ]
no shame
no force good grades we just eat the
fish
[ __ ] fish
yeah that sounded weird sorry
yeah
after what we just watched i don't know
if i agree with that you know
sharks however they
now they devil they slam it out
oh what about dolphins
oh oh do not look at dolphins dolphins
are the foulest sexual predators they're
dirty yeah have you seen that image of
the dolphin using a fish to do what
oh
have you seen that no no i haven't you
bout to show me oh god
hell yeah
look i can just see his freaking like
dolphin face already like he's looking
like yeah
what
there it is
they're ready
we eat the fish now [ __ ] doll fans
that's right pescatarian gang
taking care of these shoes
that donald just prepared that one
especially for you
ending this video on a positive note
thank you ken for watching this with me
i really appreciate that we check out
more videos with me and ken link in
description
and if today
is
your birth
if today is your birthday
happy birthday
are you waiting on me yes yes i was oh
sorry today's your birthday happy
birthday
if today's your vegan declaration day
then don't go tell everybody about it
because we don't care oh
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express
still emotions what means
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this